[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the death of a mod arbory trial there
was no report made by mr english of a
burglary at his residence why this
witness testimony could be a game
changer for the prosecution and the
conservatorship of britney spears could
soon be over what that ruling would mean
for the famed pop star plus a victory
for former president donald trump as an
appeals court temporarily blocks the
release of his january 6th records and
later the contentious case of kyle
rittenhouse i think what you're doing is
the best thing under all the
circumstances yes has anybody threatened
you or pressured you or forced you in
any way no we go inside the courtroom
for the last time before next week's
closing arguments law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
everyone to law and crime daily i'm
imran ansari filling in for brian
buckmeyer along with me in new york is
co-host terry austin
we begin with the death of a mod arbory
trial in georgia defense attorney kevin
gough offers his apologies after saying
quote we don't want any more black
pastors coming in here when reverend al
sharpton made an appearance in the
courtroom
my statements yesterday were overly
broad
i will follow up with a more specific
motion on monday
putting that and those concerns in the
proper context and my apologies to
anyone who might have inadvertently been
offended
goff represents william roddy bryan a
defendant in the case alongside father
and son gregory and travis mcmichael all
three face several charges in the death
of ahmad arbury including mannless
murder felony murder and aggravated
assault
in february of 2020 gregory and travis
mcmichael tailed arbory in their pickup
truck as he went for a jog
travis mcmichael eventually shot arbory
and now he's claiming self-defense brian
followed along in his own pickup truck
and recorded the incident in a now
famous viral video
at the time of the shooting aubry was
unarmed and jogging near his brunswick
georgia home
all three defendants faced life in
prison if conv convicted
our own brian buckmeyer is covering the
trial live in georgia brian
friday saw some intense developments
that came out of cross-examination what
happened
absolutely imran during the testimony of
officer rash prosecutor donkowski and
defense attorney franklin hogue went
back and forth about whether or not this
officer could define burglary but just
before objecting donankowski let the
witness explain
at that point in time there not had been
a crime reported there was no report
made by mr english of a burglary as
residents i was not on duty today
that he called had mr english called the
police department and made a formal
report
if
weeks later i would have had come in
contact with mr alberta and identified
him
then i would notify
the whichever officer took their report
and say i have identified this male
here is his name that officer
that himself
or it may have been handed off to our
cid criminal investigation vision
one of them would have followed up and
looked into that myself that was not the
being i was not the officer who took
that report i would not be the one
following up doing that investigation
and i'm not suggesting you would have
been the one to go out and investigate
the burglary but some investigator would
have in the normal course of things
right an officer and or an investigator
officer raz's explanation seems to
suggest that if there was a burglary
complaint which there wasn't that an
officer would have to identify aubry
then investigate the case for there to
be a burglar investigation or arrest
suggesting that the officers didn't have
probable cause based on what the
officers knew prior to february 23rd
thus neither would the mcmichaels and
with no probable cause there's no
citizen's arrest then the court broke
for lunch during the lunch break jason
sheffield attorney for trusting michael
came out and said that kevin goff's
comments that they do not want any more
black pastors was quote asinine and not
endorsed at the time in which it was
said he quoted saying that he merely
just sat there and was surprised that it
was heard or that it was endorsed
afterwards as he alone came out and
spoke that the other defense attorneys
did not agree court continued after
officer rash's testimony with officer
seacrest testimony where video of the
officer and william bryant was played
while brian described the chase
now brian i'm still shocked at the
statement what kind of aftermath did we
see after kevin goff called for no more
black pastors in the courtroom
so it was interesting we saw not only uh
in the court but in just the community
generally
first
benjamin crump as well as lee merritt
made social media post with ben crum
saying he was going to come here with a
hundred black pastors sometimes next
week we're going to still wait and see
if that occurs i got to speak with a
number of sheriffs who are concerned
that they may have more people coming
down here where for up to this point has
been pretty peaceful and well run by
both activists and family members
and brian kevin goff threw out the term
carjacking in his cross-examination
how did that play out in court
so he brought up that term when
questioning officer seacrest that's the
individual officer who questioned
william bryan when he was just merely a
witness and this is in relation to that
handprint on the door uh or pa or
driver's side sorry of the truck and
we've heard that william bryan's defense
attorney kevin gough has tried to
describe this as uh mr aubry trying to
get into the vehicle but this was the
first time that he used that
inflammatory term of carjacking which
was objected to and i believe sustained
but even the officer who was on the
stand shut him down and said that he
would not describe this as a carjacking
considering that a mod armory was being
chased as the prosecution is saying for
over five minutes that an individual who
is trying to evade being angled or
cornered or pushed off the road into a
ditch as william bryan described would
not be attempting to carjack as the
defense attorney kevin gough was trying
to argue hey brian kevin gough not
choosing his words wisely brian thank
you for your great reporting as always
and now on to news out of south carolina
where a settlement is reached in the
lawsuit involving disgraced lawyer alec
murdoch and his former housekeeper's
family all this as murdoch is denied
bond for a second time
this week a judge ruled murdoch could
not be released on bond saying a psych
evaluation confirms he is a danger to
himself and the community murdoch faces
two sets of charges the first stem from
a misappropriate settlement fund in the
death of his family housekeeper gloria
satterfield satterfield died
mysteriously on the murdoch family
property in 2018 an autopsy was never
performed her children claim they never
received any settlement money but this
week reach an agreement with the
involved bank
murdoch also faces charges for a botched
suicide for hire scheme
so that his surviving son could receive
a 10 million dollar payout from a life
insurance policy
all this comes months after his wife and
son were murdered on family property
murdoch has since been named as a person
of interest in that case
and on this week's episode of law and
crimes network's cocktails and cocktails
podcast sergeant sean sticks-larkin
hears from former los angeles county
sheriff's department detective fred
reynolds
we had a case
we find
a suitcase on the sidewalk it's like
seven o'clock in the morning
and some lady on her way to work she
sees the suitcase on this on the on the
sidewalk and then has blood coming from
the side of it
so she calls the patrol unit out
patrolling you to get there you know and
it's kind of like hey this is this
doesn't look right so we need to call
detectives
we get out there man and there is a
woman
her name is carmen viegas never forget
her name there is a woman
uh stuffed inside that suitcase naked
and the autopsy later revealed that she
had been stabbed like 81 times okay so
one so somebody raped this poor woman
stabbed her 81 times put her in a
suitcase and dumped her on a sidewalk
and confident
this week's episode is available now on
apple podcast or wherever you listen to
podcasts and still ahead on law and
crime daily former president trump's
white house records still under wraps at
least for now when we could see the
january 6 documents from the former
commander-in-chief
but first britney spears may soon be
freed over a 13-year long
conservatorship what's ahead for the
famed pop star after this
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galil gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
[Music]
welcome back to lawn crime daily and
after 13 years the conservatorship of
pop star britney spears may soon come to
an end
in a hearing set for friday a los
angeles judge is expected to terminate
at least one part of the arrangement
including control of spears finances
daily activities social life and medical
treatment
the 39 year old was under her father
jamie spears oversight beginning after
her public breakdown in 2008.
jamie spears remained her appointed
guardian until september of 2021 when he
was suspended from the conservatorship
spears case is especially unique in that
she has continued to perform and work
extensively as a global celebrity admits
the conservatorship that deemed her
unable to care for her own finances
if the conservatorship is suspended
spears legal battle will continue as her
attorneys filed a petition to depose her
father related to allegations he
illegally placed recording devices in
her bedroom
so let's bring in my co-host terry
austin and law and crime legal analyst
dina dahl to break this down terry i'm
going to start with you this case has
put a focus on conservatorships in the
united states how do you think this will
make a change in the way conservative
ships are handled in the future
it's already making some substantial
changes across the country to get a
conservative ship you have to have a
court order and it's usually by a
relative or a third party and it happens
when someone is lacking the mental
ability to make decisions either over
their person or over their finances and
they're about 1.3 million across the
country but this case has really
highlighted what's going on some of the
changes include making it easier to end
the conservatorship so if someone makes
that request they don't have so much to
prove the other thing is limiting the
conservatorship so it's not over
everything just over that limited aspect
that the individual has difficulty
controlling
yeah and dina spears's attorney argued
that she has been of sound mind for some
time but remained under the
conservatorship for more than a decade
is there any possibility for retribution
should spears be freed of the
conservatorship
it's impossible i mean her attorney has
basically already said that they are
going to be looking into the finances of
whether or not her father had any
mismanagement so certainly they will
pursue that if ms spears decides to as
well as you mentioned this illegal
recording you know in the state of
california it is illegal to record a
conversation without the other person's
consent
whether or not the security firm is
implicating that mr spears himself that
may also unfold into some liability
right great analysis you two and now
we're moving on to international legal
news olympic runner and convicted
murderer oscar pistorius is up for
parole after serving nearly eight years
in prison in south africa back in 2013
pistorius was sentenced to 15 years in
prison for the murder of his girlfriend
pistorius admitted he shot riva
steenkamp four times but claimed he
mistook her for an intruder
pistorius has served half of his
sentence which automatically qualifies
him for parole under south african law
before parole is granted pistorius will
undergo psychological evaluations social
worker meetings and a mediated
conversation with steen camp's parents
ahead of the deadly shooting pistorius
made headlines as the first olympic
sprinter who was also a double amputee
pistorius had both legs amputated below
the knee as a child
and coming up on law on crime daily the
divisive case of accused murderer kryl
rittenhouse is nearing verdict watch
plus a victory for former president
donald trump if only for a few weeks
what a federal appeals court ruled
regarding his january 6 records
all that and more after the break
[Music]
welcome back a federal appeals court
grants former president trump a
temporary victory blocking his white
house records from the so-called january
6th committee on thursday the court
granted a last-minute administrative
injunction meaning trump won't have to
release any documents just yet
this ruling pushed up against an
original friday deadline when the
national archives were set to release
trump's white house records to the
committee
all this stems from the january 6 riots
and attacks on the u.s capitol former
president trump argues executive
privilege over the emails memos and
conversation records leading up to the
riots he also says witnesses subpoenaed
by the committee should not have to
answer questions
most notably former trump adviser steve
bannon refused to comply with a subpoena
and now is the subject of a criminal
referral to the justice department
president biden shot down trump's claim
of executive privilege saying the
national archives should release the
records on thursday the appeals court
asked lawyers for trump congress and the
biden administration to submit briefs
ahead of oral arguments now set for
november 30th
dina and terry let's break this down
dina i'm going to start with you former
president trump is working overtime to
keep these records a secret
what information could possibly be in
those records and how could they
possibly incriminate donald trump
the documents that are under this
executive privilege claim include
presidential diaries
activity logs
call logs visitor logs and draft
speeches so all of those could be
helpful to the committee to determine
who president trump was talking to
around january 6 what kind of phone
calls he did or did not make that day in
the middle of the attack on the capitol
and also these draft speeches what was
the language like
you know in the drafts before this
speech he did ultimately give that day
yeah and terry president biden has
stated that former president trump
cannot assert executive privilege and
that trump must turn over these records
could that hurt biden in the future
it could hurt biden but i think that is
the proper argument i think that this
privilege is an executive privilege and
it only applies to the incumbent because
he is the executive at that time but
eventually biden will be out of office
and it could very well be one day people
are calling for his diaries and his
calendars and he would lose the argument
at that point if in fact it prevails
yeah it's a temporary injunction and we
will see how it plays out in court and
when we come back the contentious case
of accused kenosha shooter kyle
rittenhouse is nearing verdict watch
hear from the case's judge who explains
the potential outcomes written house
could face
welcome back to law on crime daily and
both sides rest in the fast-paced trial
of wisconsin versus kyle rittenhouse
ahead of monday's jury instructions both
sides focused on the charges in the case
eighteen-year-old rittenhouse faces
charges of reckless murder and attempted
murder in connection to the august 25th
2020 shootings in kenosha wisconsin
two men joseph rosenbaum and anthony
hubert died as a result of the shootings
gage gross kroitz was shot and wounded
but survived britton house's team argues
the defendant was acting in self-defense
that night the judge ruled the jury
could stay home on friday as the defense
and prosecution went head on written
house's lesser included chargers in the
end judge schroeder explained to
rittenhouse what outcome the jury could
find after hearing closing arguments on
monday
by
having a lesser included offense
included
you're
raising the risk of conviction
although you are
you're
there's you're avoiding the possibility
that the jury
will
end up compromising on the more serious
crime
and you're also
increasing the up
decreasing the risk that you'll end up
with a second trial because the jury is
unable to agree
if the jury finds that
none of the crimes charged in the
sequence
charged or submitted
has been proved beyond a reasonable
doubt then they must
quit you they must find you not guilty
and they cannot convict you of more than
one crime
on each count
okay so a less dramatic day in court but
an important one nonetheless
dina now that the case is drawing to a
close how well do you think rittenhouse
has been able to establish a
self-defense argument
what we all saw in the courtroom their
his testimony the witnesses the defense
put forward was very strong for the
defense but we cannot discount what
happened today as you said it's less
dramatic but very helpful for the
prosecution because they're going to
have an instruction regarding
provocation did he provoke it
what should he have retreated when you
see the facts of this case that's
essentially what happened he did provoke
it and he didn't retreat and that might
be the difference between guilt and
innocent that and the lesser included
charges are also very important and
could also go a long way to the
prosecution pulling off a conviction
here despite the fact that they had a
very bad day in court
yeah dina i agree and terry the
prosecution ran into a lot of trouble
with the judge how well do you think the
prosecution did overall
i think overall binger missed some
opportunities there's no question that
judge schroeder really disliked finger
because they got into that major
argument about written houses right to
silence and the fact that finger almost
crossed that line and the judge was also
angry that he thought that binger was
trying to put in evidence that he had
already ruled could not come in on these
you know prior instances but overall i
think bingo should have included those
lesser included charges because he had
to fight today to get the jury
instructions worded the way he wanted
and to get those lesser included charges
and you heard the judge there explaining
to rittenhouse how that could be pros
and cons having more charges means he
could basically be convicted having
fewer charges could work against him but
it could work for him so i definitely
think bingor should have started out
with those charges giving the jury an
opportunity to consider all of the
possibilities against written house so
at the end of the day i guess we'll see
what happens
yeah we will all be watching those
closing arguments on monday thank you
for joining us here at law and crime
daily we will see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
you